Oh
It's Chica's birthday
Yay!
She's three years old!! three years old!! three years old!! three years old!!!!
boo boo boo oh
I love you. I love you Chica
Chica, I love you. Does those words mean nothing to you? [kisses] >,< I love you Chica
Yeah Chica is three years old! *chuckles*
So today
We're gonna be celebrating her birthday
And remembering all the amazing videos that she has been a part of-- where are you going, Chi?
Did you want me to hold you like a baby? There's a little better? Huh we support your back with my back? *chuckles* Love you
So yeah, it is chicas birthday
So I wanted to just say thank you everybody that has welcomed her to the channel so much if anything (Aww <3)
She's a bigger part of this channel than I am and that's really saying something
But I just wanted to say you know all the fan art of Chica
Everything that you guys do to support Chica everything you guys like
God. Just everything you do to help out this dog here. This is wonderful... Words can't really describe how much Chica has changed my life
I knew I always wanted a dog to call my own and umm
Chica is the best dog I could have ever asked for. I had no idea what I was getting into. she is super weird
Just like me and she's just such an incredible fit into my life. I can't imagine...
living without her and we're gonna have a great birthday together
we've got cake for we've got a bunch of gifts, Amy got her stuff, Amy got her cake and uhh...
We're just gonna celebrate her birthday all day long all right I'll let you down
Sorry, oh that's such a good puppy doh
oh that's such a good puppy
oh
That doesn't look like I'm petting Chica right now, but I-I swear I am!
I swear, I'm petting her
Good girl! I can't imagine having any other dog in my life
She has just been such a heartwarming addition to my family
She's been an inspiration for me, and she's just been helping me, and she's been there for me
And my lowest times you know any time, I'm down or sad she always knows and she comes over
she's just such a personable dog and
Yeah, I wouldn't be the same without it and in that fashion
I've got a few more Chica's World's videos that I'm going to post today
here on the channel
And I wanted you guys to remember some of the best videos that she's ever been in, in the description
I provided some of my favorite videos that she's ever been in there's, 'Boat Dog', obviously there's 'Chef Dog'
There's one of my personal favorite videos, and I think it's a lot of people's even though. It's a little sad
It's called 'Chica Had Surgery'
It's when I got her fixed and she was so high on painkillers that she couldn't move it was
It was really sad at the time, but every time I look back on it. It warms my heart it is such a
*chuckles* Beautiful video
Because she's so cute, and then there's
'Markiplier's photo booth fun with Chica', 'Chica in
slow motion', one of my favorites that was back when she was still really shy and unsure of where she was it was like only the
The first or second week that I got her and then of course the first video
She was in: 'Markiplier Gets A Puppy' where you first get introduced..
And oh! my personal favorite besides 'boat dog' all those other ones, is called
'Chica chases a light on the wall and almost gots it because she is a good girl'
it is a beautiful video, and it's just one where Bob and Wade were over and
Bob was just shining a light on the wall
And Chica just kept going for the light because she loves lights cause she's such a good girl, so
Anyway, thank you everybody so much. I know there's been tons of well wishes for her birthday already and just thank you guys everybody
that's made fan art made little gifts for her and just
Yeah, thank you. Chica is such an important part of this channel, and you know she's like all of our dog
She's everyone's she loves everyone and you know
I'm just  happy to have her. So thank you everybody so much for watching! there will be more cool stuff coming today
so don't worry about that, but check out some of the videos that she's been in down in the description and
Comment your favorite video that she's been in down in the comments as well
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh, bye!